Prof: So this is where
we were at the end last time,
trying to decide when a high
HOMO, or a low LUMO,
is unusual in its energy;
because, as the world is,
things like to be at low
energy.
We'll talk about that later,
why that's so.
But that means that electrons
tend to be in the occupied,
the low -- occupy the
low-energy orbitals and not the
high-energy orbitals.
So that empty orbitals are
almost always higher than any
occupied orbitals.
So if you want to get good
energy match,
and therefore mixing,
and therefore bonding,
the occupied orbital that
you're interested in must be
unusually high,
and the vacant orbital must be
unusually low.
So the task we have is to
recognize what orbitals should
be unusually high and what ones
should be unusually low,
and if we can find the unusual
ones,
then we'll know what's
reactive, be able to identify
functional groups.
Okay, so unusual,
compared to what?
Compared to normal occupied and
vacant orbitals.
That is, in organic chemistry,
or in most kinds of chemistry
actually, carbon-carbon,
carbon-hydrogen bonds are
occupied orbitals;
not unusually high,
they're our standard of usual.
And the antibonds,
corresponding antibonds are
unusual -- are the usual vacant
orbitals.
So what can make things
unusually low or unusually high?
When the valence-shell orbitals
that,
if they bonded,
would go down and up,
don't bond with anything,
don't mix with anything,
then they'll be unusual.
Second, if the orbitals don't
overlap, then they don't go down
and go up.
Third, if you have an unusual
atomic orbital.
These are made of carbon and
hydrogen, going down.
But if you start with something
that's unusual,
unusually high or unusually
low, then the things that come
from it will be unusually high
or unusually low.
And finally, electrical charge.
So right at the end last time
we were looking at the first
example: unmixed valence-shell
atomic orbitals.
So we saw that the simplest of
all acids, H^+,
of course is unusually -- if it
were occupied,
it would be unusually high for
an occupied orbital.
Right?
Because it hasn't gone down.
But it's vacant,
and it's unusually low,
for a vacant orbital,
because it hasn't gone up.
And so on with these others:
an unshared pair on nitrogen;
or a little less so on oxygen.
A vacant orbital on boron
that's not bonding with anything
is an unusually low LUMO;
even though orbitals on boron
are not unusually low,
because the nuclear charge
isn't very big for something
that's using the second,
n=2, quantum level
orbitals,
valence orbitals.
It's an unusually low nuclear
charge for that.
So the orbitals are unusually
high in energy,
not being attracted by more
protons.
But it's low for a vacant
orbital, if it hasn't mixed with
anything.
Okay, and finally notice that
some of these are charged:
H^+;
plus means that's a good place
to put an electron,
so unusually low;
OH^-, unusually high because of
the negative charge;
CH_3^-, especially high.
So this slide also shows the
fourth point,
that electrical charge makes a
difference on how normal
occupied and vacant orbitals
are.
Okay, so these unusually low
vacant orbitals are acids,
like H^+.
Unusually high occupied
orbitals are bases,
like OH^-, as we just showed on
the previous slide.
That means that you can mix the
high HOMO of OH^-,
with the low LUMO of H^+,
and two electrons,
the ones that were on the OH^-,
go down in energy,
and that makes a bond.
And our notation for showing
that is to draw a curved arrow,
and it gives water.
Now think carefully about what
a curved arrow means;
it's not the same as a straight
arrow.
A curved arrow designates a
shift of electron pairs.
It doesn't show that this atom
moves from here to here.
It shows that a pair of
electrons shifts,
and that pair of electrons goes
from being on the oxygen,
to being between oxygen and
hydrogen,
to form the bond.
So you start the curved arrow
where the electron pair is at
the beginning,
and you end the arrow,
put its point,
where it's going to be in the
product.
Right?
So it's not showing that an
atom moves from here to there.
It's showing that the electrons
that were formerly on oxygen are
now between oxygen and hydrogen.
The effect of that is,
of course, to pull all the
hydrogen to the oxygen.
But that's not what's being
shown by the arrow.
What's being shown by the arrow
is how the electrons are moving
in our picture.
Okay, so there's a case.
Now here's another base with
the same acid,
and we can draw a curved arrow
there and show making an
ammonium ion out of ammonia.
Or we could use the same base
with a different acid,
the low vacant orbital of BH_3,
and draw the same curved arrow,
and make this anion,
make the boron-oxygen bond.
Or we could start with
completely different ones.
We could start with ammonia,
not OH^-, not Arrhenius's base,
but ammonia;
not Arrhenius acid,
H^+, but BH_3.
But it's exactly the same
reaction.
The high HOMO mixes with the
low LUMO to form a new bond.
Okay?
So that's what curved arrows
show, and don't confuse it by
trying to draw molecules or
atoms moving,
and showing a curved arrow.
If you want to show them
moving, draw some other kind of
arrow;
draw dotted arrows or a
straight arrow or a wiggly
arrow, or something.
But the curved arrows have a
very specific meaning.
Now the second reason that
things could be unusually high
or low is because they don't
have much overlap.
Notice in the first case,
it was just an extreme case of
that.
There was no overlap at all,
the orbitals were just there.
But even though the orbitals
are mixed with something else,
if the overlap is poor,
they haven't changed very much,
they still look very much like
they did originally.
Right?
So a good example of not having
very good overlap is the
side-to-side overlap of p
orbitals.
The π overlap -- you
remember from looking at those
curves of amount of overlap for
different orbitals versus
distance --
the π overlap isn't
very big.
So even though the p
orbitals start a little higher
on carbon than they do on
hydrogen,
or normal bonds of carbon that
have s character in them,
they start a little higher,
but they don't mix very much.
Right?
So the π orbital is
unusually high,
and the π*
antibonding orbital is unusually
low,
because they didn't go down or
up very much.
Okay?
Now, which of those do you
think is more remarkable,
in its highness or lowness?
So for this reason,
the carbon-carbon double bond
could behave either as an acid
or as a base.
Right?
High occupied orbital makes it
a base;
low vacant orbital makes it an
acid.
And indeed, it does have both
kinds of reactivity.
But which do you think is more
pronounced?
Which would be more familiar,
how high the occupied one is,
or how low the vacant one is?
Lucas, what do you say?
Student:  How low the
vacant one is.
Prof: And why do you say
so?
Student:  Because
electrons have to sort of --
they would likely move into a
position of an energy as close
as possible to it.
Prof: Yes,
but on the other hand,
the electrons of the
π want to move into
something else.
Student:  There are lots
and lots and lots of electrons
going up.
Prof: Well there are
lots -- there are even more
vacant orbitals than there are
electrons.
Right?
Student:  Because you
also have starring electrons
that will -- like in a normal
carbon atom.
Prof: Let's just look at
the picture.
Yes Catherine?
Student:  I think the
HOMO is more unusual because
it's farther away from the usual
--
Prof: Ah,
the HOMO is further above the
normal bonds,
than the LUMO is below the
normal antibonds.
Why?
Student:  Because the
p orbital started --
Prof: Can't hear very
well.
Student:  Because the
p orbital started a
little higher.
Prof: Ah,
because they started a little
higher.
Right?
So most reactions that we'll
study,
or at least many reactions that
we'll study of the carbon-carbon
double bond,
it's reactive because of the
high HOMO,
not because of the low LUMO;
although there are cases where
the low LUMO makes it reactive.
But it's this π
orbital, here,
that makes it particularly
remarkable, because they started
a little high.
Okay, so the high HOMO makes it
unusually reactive.
Now how about the C=O double
bond?
Right?
So it starts with the same
p orbital on the carbon,
which has π overlap
and therefore not much shifting
up and down,
with a p orbital of
oxygen, which of course is lower
than that of carbon,
because of the higher nuclear
charge.
Which of these will be most
unusual?
Somebody got a suggestion?
So what would you think the
characteristic reactivity of a
C=O double bond --
would it be reactive mostly as
a high HOMO --
that is, as a base -- or mostly
as a low LUMO?
Which is more unusual,
compared with what we compare
things with?
Andrew?
Student:  I think it's a
low LUMO.
Prof: Why?
Student:  First of all
it can't -- it's further away
from its origin.
Prof: And why is it
further down,
compared to what we usually
compare?
Why does the π*,
C double bond O,
why is that orbital so very
low?
Pardon me, one reason it's low
is because the overlap isn't
very much.
So it didn't go up so much.
Right?
That's the same,
true with a C-C double bond.
But what's special about the
C-O double bond Andrew?
Student:  I thought the
atoms are different,
there's a --
Prof: Because of the bad
energy match,
it didn't go up very much from
the carbon, or down very much
from the oxygen.
But the average is low,
that it starts from.
So what's special here is the
π is not so unusual,
not so far from here.
But this one,
π*,
is very far from here.
So what should make a carbonyl
especially reactive is its low
vacant orbital,
because of poor overlap;
and that it started with an
oxygen, an unusually low
orbital, atomic orbital.
Okay?
We saw another example here.
The three-membered carbon ring
is unusually reactive,
for a carbon-carbon bond.
That is, the electrons in that
carbon-carbon bond are not
shifted down so much,
and the antibond is not shifted
up so much,
as in normal carbon-carbon
bonds.
Why?
What's special about the bonds
in the three-membered ring?
Kevin?
Student:  Well two of
them are bent.
Prof: Ah, they're bent.
And what does that mean?
Student:  Greater than
90°.
Prof: Yes,
but they're bent,
so what?
Student:  It overlaps,
there are better overlaps.
Prof: Does it overlap as
well?
So it doesn't go up and down as
much.
Right?
So another example of poor
overlap.
Okay, or you could have an
unusual atomic energy orbital in
the molecular orbital.
For example,
how about a C-F single bond?
Right?
So the overlap can be perfectly
good.
It's a regular old
σ bond,
straight on.
Right?
But the fluorine starts very
low.
There's bad energy match.
So the π* isn't so
very different from a vacant
orbital on carbon;
unusually low as a vacant
orbital.
So it should act as an acid.
Things that have high HOMOs
should come up and react with
that σ* of C-F.
It's an unusually low LUMO.
Can you think of what the flip
side of that --
how could you have something
like this,
a carbon bonding to something,
that for the same or analogous
reason would have an unusually
high occupied orbital?
What would you want the carbon
to bond with?
Choose an element.
Student:  Lithium.
Prof: Lithium.
Why lithium?
Student:  Because --
Prof: Because you looked
at the PowerPoint?
Student:  No.
Prof:
>
Student:  I didn't look
at it.
Prof: Why lithium?
Student:  Because its
valence electron -- it's easy
for the valence electron to be
given away.
Prof: Why?
Student:  Because it
would be as stable as a lithium
plus one ion.
Prof: Why?
That's restating the same
thing, right?
What's different about lithium?
Why are orbitals on lithium,
as an atom, unusually high in
energy, compared to
carbon-hydrogen?
Catherine?
Student:  Because it has
a low nuclear charge.
Prof: Because it has a
low nuclear charge.
Right?
It's right at the left end of
the table.
Okay?
So its orbitals aren't very
stable because it doesn't have
very high nuclear charge.
So it's a high energy.
And therefore it has bad energy
match.
Or it could've been lithium
that I drew here.
I happened to draw boron,
which is, for the same reason,
a lower nuclear charge than
carbon;
therefore higher energy as an
atomic orbital.
When they mix,
what's special here is the
occupied orbital,
σ,
which is unusually high,
because the average started
high.
Okay.
So boron.
You may remember that in the
first slide we showed,
boron had a vacant orbital;
that p orbital on boron
is vacant.
Unusually low.
Therefore what, acid or base?
Unusually low vacant orbitals,
which does that make it?
Student:  Acid.
Prof: Acid.
So BH_3 should be an acid.
Right?
Well what I just showed you is
what Shai?
On the previous slide;
we'll go back there.
Student:  That it had a
big B-H;
yes the B-H.
Prof: It has an
unusually high HOMO,
BH_3.
So what does that make it Shai?
Student:  It would make
it a base but --
Prof: So is it an acid
or a base?
Student:  Both.
Prof: Wilson?
Prof: It's both.
And what does that suggest,
if the same molecule is both an
acid and a base?
What do acids react with?
Students:  Bases.
Prof: So what if the
same molecule is an acid and a
base?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: It's going to
react with itself.
Two of the molecules will react
with one another.
Okay, and that's why you can't
do a crystal structure of BH_3,
because BH_3_ becomes
B_2H_6.
Let's look at how it happens.
So there's the low LUMO that
makes BH_3 an acid.
What's the high HOMO?
What's the high HOMO of BH_3?
In localized terms.
I don't mean these big things
that go over the whole molecule.
It's the B-H bond -- right?
-- which was poorly matched in
energy and so on.
So there.
Notice that the B-H bonding
electrons are big on hydrogen,
small on boron.
We saw that last lecture.
Okay?
So they should overlap like
this, right?
And the vacant orbital on the B
should stabilize these
high-energy electrons in the B-H
bond.
But now, you could imagine many
different orientations of the
top molecule that would allow
overlap.
Do you know why I chose this
particular orientation?
Which one acted as the acid and
which one is the base?
The one on the bottom,
the vacant orbital,
acted as an acid.
The one on the top acted as a
base.
So what other possibility is
there?
Yoonjoo?
Student:  So then there
also -- you could reverse the
roles of them.
Prof: Ah ha!
You could have -- so that would
make --
notice incidentally,
what I forgot to mention here,
is that there are three nuclei
being held together by that pair
of electrons now.
Originally the top molecule,
that pair of electrons,
mostly on hydrogen but partly
on boron, held the hydrogen and
the boron together.
Now that same pair of electrons
is attracted -- is helping form
a bond with a boron,
the bottom boron.
So in fact that's an unusual
kind of bond,
because it's bonding three
nuclei together,
not just two.
It's doing double,
or perhaps triple duty.
So we need a new symbol to talk
about such bonds,
and a reasonable one would be a
bond that looks like that.
It's a Y bond.
We could make it blue.
Okay?
But now we have,
as Yoonjoo said,
the vacant orbital on the top
and the high occupied orbital on
the bottom, and they can do
exactly the same thing.
So we have two of these
three-center,
two-electron bonds.
Right?
Two electrons holding three
atoms together.
Right?
Or we can draw it that way.
And that's the structure of
B_2H_6.
Two of the pairs of electrons
are each bonding three atoms
together instead of two.
Any questions about this?
Yes Alison?
Student:  Is that what
the dotted line means for --
Prof: Yes,
the dotted just means it's a
little different.
You could draw the solid Y if
you want to.
There's no really standard
notation for that.
But it's clear what it means.
It's just that a pair of
electrons is being shared among
three nuclei,
rather than two,
and their electron density is
--
correspondingly,
if you did a difference density
map,
if you could do an X-ray of
this, you'd expect electron
density to build up in the
middle of all three.
Yes Claire?
Student:  This may seem
like a stupid question but a
high HOMO, we've talked about as
a base, and a low LUMO we've
talked about as an acid.
Prof: Yes.
Student:  And the low
LUMO is unoccupied.
If you think about it,
it's sort of receiving
electrons.
Prof: Right.
Student:  But generally,
bases are supposed to receive
electrons, instead of acids,
and --
Prof: No,
you got it backwards.
Student:  Do I?
Prof: Yes.
Student:  Oh okay.
Prof: Because H^+ is an
acid.
Right?
Student:  Right.
Prof: So it obviously
can't give up electrons.
There aren't any electrons.
An acid accepts electrons.
Okay?
Think about it a little bit in
the privacy of your room,
and you'll see that.
Okay?
Student:  Does the bond
between three nuclei only happen
--
Prof: I can't hear very
well.
Student:  Does the bond
between the three nuclei only
happen here because of the
geometry of the molecule?
Student:  Yes.
And to get that,
you have to have overlap.
So if you didn't have -- if the
top BH_3_ were
oriented so that the B-H bond
were vertical and the boron was
way up at the top,
it wouldn't overlap the other
one.
So you have to -- always to get
a bond,
you have to have overlap,
because otherwise the orbitals
don't mix and you just have the
original orbitals,
as we've seen.
Student:  Is this kind
of bond very common?
Prof: Pardon me?
Student:  Is this kind
of bond very common?
Prof: No,
it's not very common,
because there are not many
really low energy vacant
orbitals running around.
Right?
Boron is a very special case.
But a lithium can do the same
thing.
But lithium doesn't have
energy, orbital energies as low
as those of Boron,
because it doesn't have as big
a nuclear charge.
So boron is particularly good
at getting this kind of thing.
And this answers the puzzle
about Lewis structures that we
raised in Lecture two,
about how can BH_3 react with
BH_3?
Right?
That's how it does it,
by making three-center bonds.
Now here's a True and False
quiz.
On the basis of what you know,
is it true that low energy
molecular orbitals result in
bonding?
True or false?
I don't think you trust me
anymore.
>
We've been saying that when you
get those low orbitals -- things
come together,
you get a low orbital -- that
results in a bond.
Lots of overlap.
>
I can't talk you into it?
Good.
That's false.
What makes a bond is
lowered energy
orbitals.
It's when things come together
and the electrons get more
stable.
It's not how low they are,
it's how much they're lowered
by the coming together,
because then pulling apart they
have to go back up again.
So it's not whether they're
high or low, it's whether they
get lowered.
Okay?
Now, compared to what?
What do they have to get lower
compared to?
Student:  By the size.
Prof: Yoonjoo?
Student:  So it's kind
of like how in Erwin and
Goldilocks you showed the
antibonding and bonding.
So wouldn't it be the reactants?
Prof: You can say
something in fewer words than
that.
What do you compare to?
When you say energy is lowered,
and that makes a bond,
what's it lowered,
compared to?
Christopher?
Student:  The atoms in
their standard states.
Prof: Well yes.
It wouldn't necessarily be
between atoms,
it could be between two
molecules, like BH_3 with BH_3.
But you're right.
What it's lowered compared to
is the things it was before they
came together.
Right?
Now these things,
before they came together,
one of them had electrons,
one didn't.
Those might've been very high.
Right?
So they came together.
The electrons went
substantially down,
but still aren't so very low.
They could've been very
low-energy orbitals to begin
with, but not gone down very
much, because there was bad
overlap say.
So these, even though they're
lower than the ones we talked
about first, would not be so
bonding.
It's these that were bonding,
because they came down a lot,
when the mixing happened.
So it's lowering.
Compared to what?
Compared to the separated
components, before you made this
bond.
Right?
So when things come together,
and that results in the
electrons going way down in
energy, that's a strong bond.
Yes, Chenyu?
Pardon me?
Student:  How far does
it have to go down?
Prof: Well that's what
we're going to have to learn.
That's a question of lore.
Right?
And it has to be at least
enough to overcome the fact that
when they come together other
electrons,
other orbitals,
filled orbitals are
overlapping,
which is net repulsive.
So it may not be that there's
an absolute criterion.
Right?
It may be that if there are a
lot of other things opposing the
coming together,
filled orbital with filled
orbital,
then you have to have really
enormous going down.
So you can't make a simple
answer to that.
But we'll learn as we see
examples.
Okay.
So now, HOMO/LUMO mixing,
for reactivity and resonance.
So reactivity means between
molecules.
So far we've been talking
mostly about atoms coming
together and forming a bond.
But molecules have high
orbitals and low orbitals,
as in the case of BH_3.
The B-H was a molecular
orbital, or not an atomic
orbital.
Right?
So when things come together,
orbitals are orbitals.
If you have an unusually high
energy and an unusually low
energy, and they overlap and go
down, that makes a bond.
So that's between
molecules.
But it turns out that what
resonance is,
is HOMO/LUMO mixing,
within a molecule.
Now you might say the molecules
have certain molecular orbitals.
How can you mix them? Right?
The idea is that we made our
first analysis on the basis of
localized orbitals:
σ,σ*
here;
not these big Chladni things
that go over the whole thing.
But it may be that this
σ,σ*,
and this
are near one another and
overlap.
So that when we made our
initial analysis,
and looked only at this and
only with this,
we didn't take into account
that this one might interact
with this one,
and give still lower energy.
When that kind of thing is
important, that's when you have
to draw other resonance
structures.
And I'll show you an example.
But first I'm going to show you
reactivity, and then we'll go on
to resonance.
Okay, now let's look at the
frontier orbitals for H-F.
Okay?
So it has four valence electron
pairs and five valence atomic
orbitals;
2s, 2p_x_y_z on
fluorine, and a 1s on
hydrogen, and four pairs of
electrons.
So there are going to be four
occupied orbitals.
And this is what the lowest
orbital looks like.
What does it look like?
Prof: Well it's a 2s
orbital, the 1s being
the core on fluorine.
But it's made up of atomic
orbitals.
Is it exactly a 2s of
fluorine?
Does it look like sphere on
Alison, you're shaking your
head.
Student:  It's a little
bit distorted.
Prof: And how did it get
a little distorted?
What did we mix with the F
orbital?
Student:  The H.
Prof: A little bit of
the 1s on hydrogen.
It's mostly the F on
fluorine.
Why?
Because the fluorine's way down
in energy.
So the best combination is
mostly this.
But you can see that it's a
little bit egg shaped,
a little bit drawn out toward
the hydrogen.
Okay, so it's mostly a
2s of fluorine,
but a little bit of 1s
on hydrogen.
Right?
Now here's the next one.
What's that mostly?
Can you see?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: Tyler,
what do you say?
Student:  I would say a
2p.
Prof: It looks like a
2p on fluorine.
Does it look exactly like a
2p on fluorine,
or is it just hard for you to
see that it's not?
It's very similar.
Student:  I don't know,
it looks pretty close,
but the blue one might be a bit
bigger.
Prof: Yes,
the blue one is a little bit
bigger,
because it's got a little bit
of the 1s of hydrogen
lowering the energy of the
2p of fluorine.
Okay?
And now the next two orbitals
are these.
What are those?
Steve, what do you say?
Student:  The
2p_y and 2p_z.
Prof: Yes,
the 2p_y and 2p_z
of fluorine.
Is there hydrogen in those too?
Student:  Not very much.
Prof: Why not?
Student:  Because they
don't overlap with the one --
Prof: Ah,
they're orthogonal.
It's a π versus a
σ.
There's no overlap,
therefore no mixing.
So those are the occupied
orbitals.
And the 2p's have the
same energy.
Okay, and then remember there
are going to be five molecular
orbitals.
And now you make the last one,
which is going to have another
node, with the leftovers.
What's left over,
after we made the occupied
orbitals?
What's it mostly left over?
We used up the 2p's of
fluorine to make those HOMOs.
Those were pure, right?
But what was left over from the
bottom?
Students:  1s.
Prof: We used very
little of 1s on hydrogen,
and there's a little bit of
2p fluorine and 2s
fluorine that we didn't use in
the bottom ones.
So they're back in the top.
So what we have is mostly a
1s on hydrogen,
but a little bit of some kind
of sp hybrid on fluorine.
Is that clear to everyone?
So that's the vacant orbital.
Is it unusual energy,
that vacant orbital?
Student:  It's low.
Prof: It's low.
Is it unusually low?
Kate, do you have an idea?
What kind of criteria do we
have for whether an orbital
should be unusually low?
What do we look for?
Student:  We look for
overlap and energy match.
Prof: Overlap.
Energy match.
How about this case,
good overlap?
Quite good overlap.
It's a hybrid orbital on
fluorine pointed right toward a
hydrogen.
Good overlap.
How about the energy match?
Kate?
Student:  Sure.
Prof: Sure what?
Sure it's good or sure it's bad?
One of them's hydrogen.
What's the other one?
Student:  The other one
is fluorine.
Prof: Where's fluorine,
compared to hydrogen?
Student:  Fluorine is
going to be lower.
Prof: Why?
Student:  It has greater
nuclear charge.
Prof: Right.
Okay, good energy match or bad
energy match?
Student:  Not great.
Prof: Not very good.
So you don't get much mixing.
And you know that already by
looking at the picture,
because you didn't mix it very
much.
It's almost all 1s of
hydrogen.
So it's unusually low for a
σ*;
it didn't go up very much from
hydrogen.
So indeed -- now it's got an
unusually low vacant orbital.
What does that make it,
an acid or a base?
Student:  An acid.
Prof: It's an acid.
Are you surprised that H-F is
an acid?
Student:  No.
Prof: Why?
What's its name?
Student:  Hydrofluoric
acid.
Prof: Hydrofluoric acid.
And that's what makes it an
acid.
Arrhenius would say it's an
acid because it gives up H^+.
We say it's an acid because
it's an unusually low vacant
orbital.
Right?
So notice that those three are
made up of three atomic
orbitals: the 1s of
hydrogen,
the 2s of fluorine,
and a 2p orbital of
fluorine.
And they're in different
mixtures in three of these.
Usually we've looked at just
two things, right?
There's one atom,
atomic orbital,
and another one,
and they mix.
Right?
A pair.
Here there are three going in,
to give three molecular
orbitals.
But still you can see quite
easily why they should be the
way they are;
why the bottom ones are almost
pure fluorine,
and the top one is almost pure
hydrogen.
Okay.
And so that top one is
σ*;
the LUMO, the unusually low
LUMO.
Lucas?
Student:  How can we be
sure that the 1s of the
low nuclear-charge hydrogen is
going to be that much different
from the really high nuclear
charge 2s of fluorine?
Prof: Yes,
this you have to learn.
And I'm going to show you very
soon how we can tell that kind
of thing.
Okay, there's a different
picture, that was made in 1973,
of the same thing.
These pictures were drawn just
a year or two ago,
but this is -- you can see the
same thing.
It's drawn at a different
contour level.
It was based on a different
calculation.
But you can see it's the same
thing.
And we'll notice that -- how
many nodes does this thing have,
that are clearly visible?
Students:  Two.
Prof: Two nodes, right?
Between the H and F.
That one is antibonding. Right?
When they came together they
cancelled in the middle,
rather than reinforcing.
There's another node there.
But notice that that didn't
have anything to do with the
bonding.
That was already there in the
atomic orbital you started with.
So it didn't have anything to
do with lowering.
It didn't have anything to do
with whether the thing was
bonding or antibonding.
The pink node had to do with
whether it was bonding.
That came when they came
together.
Right?
It's unfavorable.
So it's better for them to come
apart.
But if they come apart,
you don't do anything with the
blue node.
It's still there,
it's part of the atom.
Okay?
So you have to recognize that
there are two kinds of nodes.
There are nodes that were there
already,
atomic orbital nodes,
and there are ones that are
associated with the coming
together,
and that's what makes something
bonding,
or antibonding;
in this particular case it's
antibonding.
Okay now let's look,
instead of H-F,
let's look at CH_3-F.
Sam?
Student:  Why is it
called a frontier?
Prof: Because you have
occupied orbitals,
and then you have vacant
orbitals, and the ones you're
interested in are the lowest of
the vacant and the highest of
the occupied,
at this border between occupied
and vacant orbitals.
Okay, so this one has seven
valence pairs of electrons.
So you're going to occupy seven
orbitals.
And here's what they look like,
the seven that are occupied.
What's the very lowest one,
mostly?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: It's the 2s
of fluorine.
Right?
And what's the next one?
Well it's C-H bonds,
all mixed together.
Right?
But also a little bit of a
p orbital on fluorine.
It has the blue,
sort of, toward the front,
and a little bit of that red
behind, as part of the p
orbital on fluorine.
So it's a mixture of the C-H
bonds and of the p
orbital on fluorine.
And then we have these others,
some of them coming in pairs,
and those are the HOMOs,
because we have seven occupied.
And let's look at them a little
more closely and compare them,
each one, with the one beneath
it.
And I'll draw another picture
too, of that older kind,
for making this comparison.
And we're interested in what is
it that went together,
to make these orbitals,
and why is one lower in energy,
and the other higher?
So what do you see on the top
orbital, say this one here,
the top left;
what's that made up of?
What is it on the left side?
Sophie, what would you say the
orbital is on the left side of
that?
Student:  I think it's
2p over there.
Prof: Right.
This part here is a 2p
π orbital of fluorine.
Now what's this thing on the
right here, the dash bit down
here?
If you just saw that,
without any of the rest of it,
what would you say that was?
Students:  1s.
Prof: It's more than a
1s on hydrogen;
that would be spherical.
It's, at a certain contour,
the C-H bond.
Do you see that?
So this is electron density in
here, bonding between C and H.
And these two on the top are
little bits of C-H bonds as
well, mixed together.
So what this orbital is,
is a mixture between some
combination of C-H bonds on the
right, and the p orbital
of fluorine on the left.
Now is it a favorable,
or an unfavorable combination,
of the fluorine orbital with
the C-H orbitals?
This one up here.
Is the interaction between the
fluorine orbital and the C-H
orbitals bonding or antibonding?
Students:  Antibonding.
Prof: Becky,
do you have an idea?
Are they building up electron
density in between,
or having a node in between?
Student:  A node.
Prof: There's a node in
between.
So that's antibonding.
What's the orbital on the
bottom, this one?
Student:  Bonding.
Prof: That's the same
components, but it's the bonding
combination.
So this is the favorable
combination of those,
and this is their unfavorable
combination.
So this lower-energy one is
favorable, and the upper energy
is unfavorable combination.
How about here and here?
Can you see what that is?
What's on the left,
here, that lump of red and this
lump of blue?
Eric?
Here, this thing,
it's very complicated.
Okay, will you agree on that?
Student:  Okay.
Prof: But part of it,
this part on the left,
there's a red lump in behind
and a blue lump in front.
You can see it maybe more
clearly here.
Red behind, and blue in front,
surrounding the green fluorine
atom.
What is that orbital,
that atomic orbital?
Student:  Probably the
p orbital.
Prof: Can't hear very
well.
Student:  Probably the
p orbital,
a different orientation.
Prof: It's the p
orbital on fluorine that's
pointing more or less toward
you.
Okay?
So this is the p orbital
of fluorine, that's mixing with
C-H bonds here.
Right?
In fact, it's the same thing as
this, turned on its side.
Okay?
So this is the bonding
combination, built up between
the fluorine and the C-H's.
This is the antibonding one,
with a node between the
fluorine and the C-H's.
So here we have a node,
in this bottom one,
but that node came from the
atomic orbitals.
That's what made it a p
orbital here,
on fluorine.
That one, you don't get rid of,
if you pull the fluorine away.
That doesn't have anything to
do with the bonding,
that's just an atomic orbital
node.
Right?
On the top, you again have the
same atomic orbital node,
because it's the same p
orbital that's involved.
But what about the top?
Sam?
Student:  You have
another node but --
Prof: There's another
node, that one,
and that's an antibonding node.
Right?
The electrons in that orbital
would get lower in energy if you
broke the bond,
if the fluorine came away.
So the pink nodes are the ones
we're interested in;
the antibonding nodes,
not the ones that are just part
of the atomic orbital.
Okay.
Now, we're getting to Lucas's
question.
So this thing down here is made
up of fluorine and C-H.
The one here is made up of
fluorine and C-H.
Right?
This is the favorable
combination, and this is the
unfavorable combination.
So get it right.
So here are the two of them.
They come together when the F
comes up to the methyl.
Right?
And you get a favorable one and
an unfavorable one.
But the fluorine and the C-H's
may not be at the same energy.
How do you know which one's
lower?
That's your question.
Is the fluorine lower,
or is the C-H lower,
or are they about the same?
Now how are we going to tell?
If the fluorine is lower,
and they come together,
what does the lower one look
like, mostly?
Student:  Fluorine.
Prof: Fluorine.
If the fluorine's higher,
and they come together,
what does the low one look
like?
Student:  C-H.
Prof: Mostly C-H, right?
So by looking at how big these
are, we can tell which one is
lower.
So when we look here,
we see that here I would say
they're pretty similar,
left to right.
There's not much difference
between a 2p orbital on
fluorine and C-H σ
bonds; not much difference.
But to the extent they're
different I would say,
looking at this,
that the C-H is a little bigger
here, and the fluorine is a
little bigger here.
Would you say that?
So which is lower,
a C-H σ bond or
the p orbital of
fluorine?
Students:  C-H.
Prof: C-H σ
bond would be a little lower
than fluorine;
not much though, pretty similar.
So they're about the same,
as we say.
But if you have to make a
choice, the C-H is a little bit
lower in energy;
the fluorine's a little higher.
Okay.
Now there's also a vacant
orbital, made up with the
leftovers here,
some of the leftovers.
And what's that?
Let's look at a different
picture of it.
So this has three nodes that
are obvious.
There's one that's near the
fluorine atom,
a node, plane,
that goes back.
The furthest to the left.
Everyone see that?
Is that an antibonding node,
or is that an atomic orbital
node?
Student:  Atomic orbital.
Prof: That's part of the
fluorine atomic orbital of some
hybrid on fluorine.
Right?
And the same is true at the C-H
end.
There's a node that's an atomic
orbital node of the carbon.
Right?
But what's important?
Between those other two is
what's between the fluorine and
the carbon, and the CH_3_.
And that's antibonding.
So that, the LUMO is a
σ* antibond,
between C and methyl.
And why is it unusually low?
The question is whether the
LUMO should be unusually low.
Why is it unusually low?
Is the overlap bad?
Student:  It's fine.
Prof: No,
the overlap's good;
the hybrids are pointing right
toward one another.
But what makes it low in energy?
So I'm not giving you specific
problems on this,
but look over those things and
run your brain as to those four
different things that make
orbitals unusually high or
unusually low.
Because that's what you'll be
doing next week when you're
doing these Wikis,
each of you,
to decide some functional
group, why is it functional?
What makes it unusually high or
unusually low;
or maybe neither? Right?
Why is the C-F bond,
more properly the C-F
σ* orbital,
the antibonding orbital,
why is it unusually low?
Compared to what?
What do you compare it to?
Student:  C-H.
Prof: A C-H bond.
How come C-F is lower,
for the σ*?
Alex?
Student:  Energy
mismatch.
Prof: Pardon me?
Student:  Energy
mismatch.
Prof: Yes,
the fluorine is really low,
their average is very low.
So the vacant orbital is
unusually low.
It didn't go up much. Right?
Where have you seen that before?
H-F.
The previous slide,
H-F, was exactly the same.
It's an acid.
Remember Kate,
you helped us with that.
It's an acid because of the bad
energy match between fluorine
and hydrogen.
This is the same thing,
but it's the bad energy match
between fluorine and carbon.
Okay.
So CH_3-F is an acid for the
same reason that H-F is an acid.
Right?
There's the low LUMO of H-F.
It's got that same antibonding
node.
Shai?
Student:  Why is there
no energy mismatch between
carbon and hydrogen?
Prof: It just happens
that it worked out that way.
But it's true.
Hydrogen is 1s.
That makes it unusually low.
But it doesn't have a very big
nuclear charge.
Carbon has a higher nuclear
charge, but you're talking
2s and 2p.
And it turns out those just
cancel out.
If that hadn't been the case,
organic chemists --
like if boron happened to match
hydrogen,
then maybe our organic
chemistry would be
boron-hydrogen,
not -- there would be
borohydrates,
not carbohydrates. Right?
But that's the way things are.
Student:  So in this
picture we can tell that --
Prof: Actually there are
other reasons it wouldn't be
boron,
because boron has these vacant
orbitals and forms B_2H_6_
and so on.
But it just happens that that
cancellation works that way.
Lucas?
Student:  Just by
looking at this picture we can
say that CH_3,
that there's poor energy match
because the orbitals around
fluorine are much smaller than
those around CH_3.
Prof: Let's look at the
next slide here.
Is it this one? No.
We're going to get to that.
If you looked at ones that were
very badly mismatched,
then the favorable and
unfavorable combinations would
be very dramatic.
Actually, you've already seen
that in H-F.
Okay, we have one minute to
start this.
Okay, so we're going to look at
how CH_3-F behaves like H-F.
Right?
Both of them are acids.
So first we'll look at H-F,
and next time we'll go on to
CH_3-F.
So here's H-F.
So you have to bring -- here's
a low vacant orbital.
We've talked about that ad
nauseam.
Okay?
Now you want to get good
overlap.
From what direction will
another orbital come,
in order to get good overlap,
without the nuclei getting too
close together?
Obviously it'll come from off
in the right,
where this orbital is big,
where you can get a lot of
overlap without getting close to
the nuclei.
So if you had something with a
high-energy pair of electrons,
it would come and it would
overlap, from the right;
something like OH^-.
And you'd draw a curved arrow,
to show those electrons;
the high HOMO of OH^-,
being stabilized by the vacant
orbital of H-F.
And how would you draw the
curved arrow?
Where would it start,
where would it end?
To show the electrons of OH^-
forming a bond with -- OH bond?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: You'd start from
the pair of electrons that
you're talking about,
and you'd end between H and
O.***Right?
But that means -- this is
really important -- that means
you're putting electrons,
putting electron density,
into this orbital.
Right?
What effect does putting
electrons in that orbital have
on the H-F bond?
Okay, the curved arrows,
blah-blah;
we did that.
Sherwin?
Student:  It's like it
pushes them out.
Prof: It's what?
What do you call that orbital?
What's the name of the orbital,
that we're putting electrons
into?
Student:  1s for
--
Prof: It's
σ*.
It's mostly 1s on
Hydrogen, but it's
σ*.
What does * mean?
Students:  Antibonding.
Prof: What does it mean
if you put electrons in?
Student:  The bond
breaks.
Prof: The bond will
break.
Right?
It has that antibonding node.
So electrons that go into that
will get more stable if the bond
breaks.
So we're going to draw another
curved arrow,
like that.
So we make a new bond between H
and O, but we lose the bond
between H and F.
So there's our product.
That's an acid-base reaction,
and it showed H-F acting as an
acid;
not because it gave H^+.
H^+ never appears in here.
Right?
What happened is you make a
bond and break a bond to the
hydrogen.
So it's an acid-base reaction.
And the same thing,
we'll show next time,
happens with CH _3-F.
Okay.